oh pardon je faisais une véritable
oeuvre d'art
excellent vous avez aujourd'hui nous
sommes sur passe partout non il ne
s'agit pas du jeu de cette légende de la
télévision française il s'agit de
l'histoire d'un autre français qui veut
percer dans le monde de l'art pour
pouvoir s'acheter des baguettes de pain
et du vin
voilà c'est un peu cliché mais bon voilà
mon avis a pas été fait par un français
mais je vais aujourd'hui percée sur le
marché du tableau de la toile est pas la
toile d'internet la toile le tissu mec
c'est parti le but c'est très simple
c'est de faire des oeuvres de l'évent de
plus en plus cher j'ai déménagé dans des
endroits de mieux en mieux est d'avoir
une vie de mieux en mieux vous avez
compris à ce pauvre jeune homme vit dans
un garage ils n'arrivent pas à percer
dans le monde de l'art son histoire est
entré triste nous allons dessiner un
homme très triste avec la coupe de
cheveux un peu à la mode rasé sur les
côtés long sur le dessus j'ai plein de
saintdo fait perdre et comme c'est bien
fait c'est incroyable les larmes coulent
sur son visage humide et plein de sébum
car il n'a pas l'argent pour acheter le
savon pour se laver
ok il est là c'est un tableau très fort
en émotions on va l'appeler sadness
pourquoi ça tu n'es ce pas ce que les
français préférent tous les noms en pas
français auront plus tendance à acheter
si je marque en anglais adorent c'est
bon le mec la boulangerie à côté qui
vivent de ses baguettes sur mon local de
professionnels abuser il faut que j'en
fasse une note
oh là là qu est ce qu on pourrait
raconter et bien vous savez quoi on va
dessiner une baguette aux mauvaises
énergies je ne l'aiment pas mais c'est
l'histoire de ma mère c'est pourquoi tu
fais ça comment te permets tu as la
coque est bas plus connu du che je vous
dessine une guitare et que vous aimerez
mieux maggie qui nous dit c'est
effectivement un tableau de merde
merci mallet c'est bien mais c'est bien
le respect présente donc en gros on a
peur on vient payer nos factures et on a
perdu 80 dollars peut-être que la
baguette le pain français bien chaud qui
sort du four va nous sauver on va
l'appeler brède
parce que si on l'appelait pinça frais 0
vente allez y avait un mec qui va aimer
j'aimerais quelque chose de plus frais
nous dit jorge ben vas sur les quais de
la seine et ferme ta gueule tapée la
tumeur il fait frais est une balle à wau
bon j'ai fait dessiner quelque chose qui
résume parfaitement l'émotion de notre
personnage à ce moment précis
voilà un bon vaut galles sur mon tableau
peut-être que damas a lancé ma carrière
peut-être sacrebleu où est l'originalité
et benjamin frères franchement retourne
t bag est à georges qui est actuellement
sur 1 400 vols vente et baguettes et
foutez moi mais peut-être qu'ils aiment
tout ce qui est abstrait
[Musique]
voilà ça voyons ce tableau l'énergie
transmise l'énergie de plusieurs bombes
nucléaires qui sont retransmises à
l'écrit ce gros tricks qui passe devant
l'oeuvre abstraite elle cacher derrière
bref on va l'appeler steuplé achète le
frère passe très bien à elles en restent
à faire mais là je sais plus là on va
juste faire une barbe
voilà ou alors ça en vrai ça peut être
un visage de quelqu'un et c'est là
qu'est la subtilité à l'envers voilà
regardez c'est ça qui est intéressant
avec ce tableau c'est qu'au premier
abord on croirait une barbe et puis
quand on tourne la tête on s'aperçoit
finalement c'est une tête à l'envers
bientôt ses excellentes énormes
provoquées
shocking afrique in glaubitz au mas
guilhem et l'art abstrait l'énergie des
bombes nucléaires ce plh et que le frère
a été vendu pour 10 euros
yes ok j'ai compris comment ils veulent
qu'on leur parle du coup je suis là on
va l'appeler mais moi bien cousin c'est
très bien ça pourquoi peinture avec
aucune passion magic maggie séchage et
au moins 18 fois je fais ça par passion
hockey et certainement pas pour la thune
[ __ ] breaking news les scientifiques
viennent de découvrir un vaisseau
spatial
ok j'ai compris le message à la up
on a fait une nature des mixains mais
bon c'est pas au alley hoop le doigt
d'honneur on l'a dégagée personne ne
veut acheter un fuck bon c'est dommage
aveugle dans ton salon mec ça mais bien
ça met les points sur les i quant à des
invités à l'udaf où il achète à 113 dans
la mondiaux merci les aliens d'être
passé sur terre [ __ ] même eu tellement
bien je pouvoir acheter du vin de 10 ans
d'âge j'ai une idée un peu sommes un
concept sobre mais efficace et de
dessiner des fruits de la manière la
plus sobre possible
voilà là on est bien non c'est pas toi
quand tu avais de la cnps à 12 ans c'est
juste une phrase voilà très bon concept
ok je propose tout simplement attention
grosse oeuvre voilà c'est abstrait
chacun interprète comme il le veut
certains y verront un pissenlit d'autres
y verront un arc en ciel on ne sait pas
achète le ou je te plante
voilà comme ça au moins on essaie régler
en 10 euros pour cette fable c'est
incroyable je prends je prends j'ai des
gens disent que la passion et la
créativité de passe-partout et le truc
le plus cool dans la rue actuellement
yates après ok les gens prennent pour un
dieu mais ils achètent mes tableaux
moins cher qui paient leur menu mac do
quand même donc bon ton mec ça mais
combien de temps à sortir de la rue là
franchement mais que c'est plus rapide
de percer dans la dans la vraie vie ou
dans le jeu quoi à 16 euros pour le le
jeu c'est plus que j'avais mise mais
c'est pas vrai si je prends cette valve
c'est parti [ __ ] le buzz quand je suis
en train de peser tout le monde veut
acheter mes tableaux d'un cookie et 6
passes et les hipsters discours que je
suis devenu trop populaire et qu'ils
achèteront plus mes oeuvres
eh ben je m'en bats les couilles barrez
vous avez vos baguettes rien à [ __ ]
les amis j'ai une grande annonce
je tiens un vrai concept cette fois
voilà très bien donc il nous reste huit
euros d'argent de poche
est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est bientôt
la fin de cette vidéo wat pho j'ai fait
six en leur honneur incroyable en ville
on n'arrête pas de parler de moi mais en
attendant je dors dans un garage un sur
un lit humide qui comporte un maximum de
cloportes je vais faire une fusée parce
que je reste mon aller loin avec
derrière du faux du feu y aura du rouge
et je veux à tes sur la lune ici et là
dans le cockpit c'est moi c'est moi qui
sut debout et qui veut aller sur la lune
parce que j'en ai marre de cette vie
voilà l'interprétation sera pas mal du
tout
comme ça c'est sympathique ouais ouais
c'est vraiment pas mal au 44 $ pour la
fusée au il a compris le message il a
compris la métaphore à travers ce dessin
parfaitement illustré ok je pense avoir
compris un truc je pense qu'ils se
basent sur le temps que tu as mis à
faire le tableau attend ça se trouve
mais que j'ai trouvé comment le jeu
marche et je vais devenir la plus grande
star de l'art de l'histoire de ce jeu
met un maximum de temps on va faire du
noir
on va attendre une minute à chaque fois
ok attend même si ça marche c'est génial
je devais une star de ouf c'est ça mec
regarde 97 il me propose les affaires
commencent
[Musique]
l'eau
oh qu'est ce qui se passe walid fois
qinghai
il a écrit un article sur moi c'est
enfin l'acte suivant on va vivre
ailleurs que dans un garage champagne
tient au bourget que le loup mais ce
paraphe la fête n'en sera que meilleur
roche est mon propre atelier dé savoie
par contre faut pas une autre heure de
jeu pour atteindre le truc d'après parce
que la mecque à un moment tout 175 euros
de factures le loyer là serait ce la fin
de passe-partout la fin d'un homme si
pur ici d'où la fin d'un homme
exceptionnel
la fin d'un homme qui a su rester forts
même dans les pires moments qu'il est
méchant
la fin d'un véritable artiste du spartoo
merci pour tous ces moments merci pour
toutes ces oeuvres d'art et à bientôt
[Musique]
photo ben et jarrod cette notion
passe-partout n'hésitez pas allez
messieurs vous a plu bon mes oeuvres ont
un peu convaincu les hipsters
mais quand je suis devenu connu il
m'aimait plus je suis triste après est
ce que ces gens qui vont à des soirées
mondaines ça faire ça eh bien non bon
j'arrête à tout jamais le dessin je vous
dis à très dans une prochaine vidéo
portez vous bien le mec il dit au revoir
alors quoi même plus sa tête
on sait même pas si ans brille pas
vraiment si c'est une preuve qu'il a
rajouté au montage
[Musique]